لا تتغير ملامح المخيم بقدر ما تتغير
ملامح اهله من اللاجئين خاصه في فصل
الشتاء معاناه ليست جديده في واقع فرضه
اللجوء لكنها الاصعب في ظل صح المساعدات
وقله التمويل قصه الحاج محمد لا تختلف عن
غيرها من قصص اللاجئين ثمن اسطوانه الغاز
هو ما اثقل كاهله اكثر من وزنها الذي
يحمله على كتفه يواجه هو واحفاده برد
الشتاء وقله المساعدات في وقت ماتت فيه
عودته للبلاد مستحيله خوفا من معاناه اكبر
هناك
بالليل
ثلاث اربع مرات مغطي فيهم وخاصه بالليل
الحمد لله
العالم انا احب اكثر
بعد هذا الملف في مواجهه مع الاصعب حيث لم
يصل حجمه الالتزام الدولي في السنوات
الاخيره للاردن اكثر من 25% اضافه لشحن
المساعدات من المفوضيه
من تداعيات الازمه الاوكرانيه
الاول والثاني كان هناك
حماسه دوليه في الوقوف الى جانبنا
خلال سنوات الاخيره لم يصل حجم الالتزام
الدولي
لا اكثر من 25% اسطوانه الغاز واحده تعتمد
عليها عائله الحاج محمد في الطبخ ووسيله
للتدفئه ايضا ايام قليله قبل نفذ هذه
الاسطوانه والموا ومع فصل الشتاء في سباق
مع الزمن ينتظرون فيه شمس يوم جديد علها
تحمل املا طوته سنوات اللجوء من مخيم
الزعتري شمال العاصمه عمان سهى جميل
العربيه